in my introductory video about taoism
i talked about how the religion has
taken on many
different forms throughout history and
that there's no
use in calling it a coherent religion in
the regular sense
everything from a politically involved
and strongly ritualistic practice to
the total escape from society and
free-flowing ascetic
attitudes it all fits under the wider
umbrella of taoism and the ways that it
has been approached
one example of the later kind we find in
an early example of taoist practice and
religion
with a group of scholars who have come
to have a legendary status in the
chinese cultural consciousness
and who are collectively known as the
seven sages
of the bamboo grove
the third century was not a very
pleasant time for china
it saw the collapse of the long-standing
han dynasty
in 220 and the subsequent descent into
political chaos
for most of the century rivaling
kingdoms and power structures
fought and ward amongst each other in
what has become known
as the infamous three kingdoms period
immortalized in different books
movies and video games and in this
period of great unrest the political and
social world was
filled with violence with corruption and
jealousy
as if that isn't the case otherwise but
while this may paint a very bleak
picture
such times of unrest can also sometimes
lead to flourishing or
very interesting developments in other
areas of society
and in a way such was the case here for
as a result of this environment we get a
very
fascinating and incredibly chilled out
group of scholars who would
as i said come to have a legendary
status to this day
you see there were a group of seven
scholars poets and
musicians who all were of pretty high
status and prominence in way dynasty
china
but they became so disillusioned with
the political corruption of
politics and the government that they
would escape to the countryside into a
specific
bamboo grove surrounded by beautiful
nature
here they would gather together to
appreciate the beauty of nature and to
compose
poetry play music together and drink
wine
some stories even claim that they may
have consumed some psychedelic
substances
now all of this was a way to escape the
chaotic and dangerous
world in the so-called civilized society
they could all be seen as taoists as
this retreat was
quintessentially a kind of taoist
practice
one of the more organized forms of
taoism that had emerged at this time was
a movement known as
jintan or pure conversation
it was characterized by an advocating of
free living
individual expression and a quote
hedonistic escape from the corrupt court
politics of the short-lived wei dynasty
and the seven sages of the bamboo grove
can very much be said to belong to this
school not as chintan or pure
conversation
if you remember the main principles of
taoism it talks about
wu way or effortless action to live
freely spontaneously and in harmony with
nature
and the tao the seven sages very much
represent this
a rejection of a kind of confusion
legalism by escaping into nature and
appreciating it
as well as flowing or being one with the
tao
through composing poetry music
and having pure conversations free
discussions among friends about
metaphysical and other philosophical
questions
i would totally like to hang out with
these people these seven sages of the
bamboo grove included
ji kang a writer poet musician and
alchemist whose
estate the bamboo group was located next
to
he was apparently an accomplished player
of the gucci
back then known only as qin which is a
chinese string instrument that has a
strong connection with taoism in
particular
there was also luijin a taoist poet and
apparently a
great lover of alcohol there was ruan
chan
another musician and player of the
ancient chinese loot
and the modern development of that
instrument that one is actually named
after him
there was chan zhou a great taoist
scholar who wrote famous commentaries on
the juanse one of the foundational texts
of taoism
wang rong an official and scholar of the
jin dynasty
there was chan tao which was another
musician and as his name suggests a
prominent taoist
and lastly the sage that is probably the
most renowned of the seven
ruan ji who was a master musician and
poet who also played the instrument
gutshin
he used to write poetry that strongly
criticized and spoke out against the
ruling class but did
so through allegory so as to hide it
from those he actually criticized
he is also said to have purposefully
remained drunk for 60 days just to avoid
being forced into an arranged political
marriage
also he seems to have a significant
impact on music and wrote many
compositions
one of the melodies that is attributed
to him known as drunken ecstasy or
drunken madness
still survives and can be heard on many
gucci
recordings these sages all had the
common wish to
escape from the world and instead live
in simplicity
in the bamboo grove they could express
their taoist ideals and love of nature
through their music and poetry some
stories for example tell how they would
enter ecstatic states jump into the
water to cool off and then start writing
inspired verses of
poetry the story of the seven sages of
the bamboo grove is a
legendary one it is of course incredibly
romantic and
inspiring in a way i think many of us
can relate to the sages and their wish
to escape
a chaotic society the question of the
authenticity of this story is undecided
the
seven sages themselves were indeed real
people who lived at this time but some
argue that the story of their regular
gathering in this bamboo grove may be
just that a story but irregardless of
its historical authenticity
the seven sages have come to play a
legendary role in the collective
consciousness of the chinese people
and to some degree outside china as well
they represent a wish for a simpler life
one
free from the complex world of politics
and societal upheaval
a life that is free expressive in the
company of good companions and in tune
and appreciation of the beauty of nature
and our connection to it the seven sages
are thus also a perfect expression of
some of the most central ideas
in the religion of taoism i think we can
all recognize ourselves
in the sages in these current times of
pandemics wars political instability and
polarization
the idea of just escaping it all to
enjoy some nice music
poetry and nature together with your
friends is
kind of unnervingly tempting so if i
suddenly stop publishing videos for a
while
you know where to find me i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you